where to place transgender offenders has
become a political Minefield and in
particular whether trans women should
ever end up in women's prisons the
government says it's taking a common
sense approach and reforming the rules
we need to protect the most vulnerable
in our society and I think where you've
got uh trans offenders trans women
offenders and the suggestion is or the
question is whether they move into the
female prison estate I think we need to
be really clear about protecting the
other female offenders prisoners in that
estate this week transgender offenders
with male genitalia will be banned from
female prisons if they've been convicted
of sexual or violent offenses with the
exemption for only exceptional cases
decided at the highest level the changes
for England and Wales follow recent Fury
in Scotland there was outrage When
Tiffany Scott utter violent trans inmate
wanted to move to a female prison and
criticism too over the case of Isla
Bryson a transgender double rapist
temporarily housed in an all-women jail
there's an urgent review and the
movement of trans prisoners is paused in
Scotland I think either Bryson is at it
if I'm honest I think they're a
dangerous individual deceptive
individual I don't think they're a true
trans women I think they're trying to
play the system for personal advantage
current prison population in England and
Wales is around 80 000 of these 230
people are transgender with just six
transgender women currently in a women's
prison
the numbers might be small but the
reforms are significant addressing a
complex and controversial issue of
current times Laura bundock Sky News